[موسيقى]
هذا هو LC إنها تنين كومودو
أكبر أنواع السحالي على الأرض اليوم
[موسيقى] يمكن
للإناث مثل LC أن تنمو لتصل إلى 6
أقدام ومن المعروف أن الذكور يصلون إلى 10
أقدام ويزن أكثر من 200 رطل وهم
صيادين شرسين ويمكنهم  تعطل
الفريسة الكبيرة مثل جاموس ماء الغزلان ، وفي
حالات نادرة ،
غالبًا ما يتسبب البشر في تلوث اللعاب في
تسمم الدم المميت في غضون 24
ساعة ، يمكن أن يستهلك تنين كومودو ما يصل إلى 80 ٪
من وزن جسمه في تغذية واحدة
موطنها خمس جزر إندونيسية كومودو
تنانين  هي إقليمية وتقضي الكثير
من وقتها بمفردها ،
تواجه هذه الحيوانات المفترسة المخيفة العديد من التهديدات
الزلازل والنشاط البركاني
، فقد أدى فقدان الموائل والصيد الجائر غير المشروع إلى تقليل
التجمعات البرية إلى بضعة
آلاف فقط هذا هو تنين كومودو